the Sheriff's Office reports that are
likely looking for a white male
preferred targets appear to be males
aged 12 to 16
it's a serial children a gate may call
it they'll receive the letter from the
individual telling themselves the
caveman Slayer there's the serial killer
loose what else could possibly be this
excited incoming titties 12 o'clock guys
Nikki you can shoot scientifically
perfect huh better view of my room than
I thought sweet dreams
emergency meeting tree house now
Mackie is to Cape May Slayer Maggie's a
cop of a sick reputation isn't counting
on us
[Music]
that's blood baby black you look like
you're 30 it's gonna be fine now go
you're gonna get caught either by Macky
or your dad I know I'm right about that
doesn't prove anything
I don't want anything bad to happen to
you trying to save people yeah well
you're not as a stationary will of this
just let it go sorry again the ferret
rounded misty bring get you out of this
house
no hard feelings
even serial killers live next door to
somebody
[Music]